[Applause]
Personally, I
have a fanfare.
[Applause]
[Music]
How many pets do
TWICE
have. Raised a turtle. A
dog that you really raise. Let's just say
two, two, two, two, two, two, one.
Then, there are five.
I have five.
Lookism was so fun. It
was new.
Dayeon said you stayed up until 3 a.m., so we did
something and we watched. Then, it was
so cute. Dayeon said
she was so cute. I really like that kind of school. Well, it's
fun. I also
like Ghibli and Disney.
But we  I didn't act a bit during the Bulldose music video.
I
watched that talk talk where something was erased, and there was something about that secret agent that
suits him well. Doesn't he look good on an action actor? Who jumps out and doesn't suit him? A very famous romance. A
man at a wedding can time travel and it's
sad. I imagine it's a
twist.  Mina was the one who killed it.
Otherwise, it goes
well with a sitcom.
I would be
over Tzuyu if it was a bit like a period drama. It's
a bit like that. She's the kind of person who can only really study, like real
glasses.
Chaeyoung is a
designer who makes clothes, and
Se-yeon has something unique about her. It's
dark.  Very
impactful Okay
[Music] I
really like this guy named Jonathan Batiste. I
listen to him a lot, so I just want to meet him. I
want to go to his concert.
[Music]
There's a rapper named Tyler, but I do
n't think we'll be able to collaborate. I
don't feel very sincere. He's so cute.
And me too.  I
always think that I am really fortunate to be on a team with the members. I
was thinking about it today as well. And somehow, I think this will become more
evident as time goes by. Really, there
is also something that we feel, and it is not easy to see it in other people's eyes,
but there is something about it.  Even if people aren't our fans,
Twice is really close to us and we
seem to get along well. It makes me feel really good to hear things like this.
[Music] Please act
this out a little bit. But even people who don't know this secretly don't have to
know younger people than they are a lot older these days.
But for me, the real Sixteen is.  I'll never see you again. You
don't really see what you were like when you were younger. There are
a lot of things we practiced that didn't
show up on screen. We became friends when we rode the bus together. And when we first got on Sixteen, we all saw each other, so that was
Bong Bong-sa-su.  I think
those
memories
[applause]
cut
your throught so you
can focus, so it's actually
better
Pro We
[laughter] But it's
okay in my heart,
even if I think it's not that hard on my neck, I
really wish I could do more, but I'm
because of this sound  Confidence is really important on that stage. Yes, there is such a thing. When
fans
meet after a long time or
something, the fans are shy and
passive at first, so when the sound is low, I
am also a little passive like this, wondering if I am doing well.
I guess you're doing well,
so I'm
totally
laughing at you. I'm doing well.
Instagram [
Music] You seem to like this
outfit,
but there's something cool about it.
And it's really hard for all of us to
harmonize and have individuality because there are 9 of us, but that's right,
each and every one of us is pretty.  I
think it's
really pretty to use just black and make it all different and unified. Also,
black is actually a pretty normal color.
But
anyway, if you're an idol or a
singer, you wear black clothes a lot, but they give
you a different feeling every time you wear it.  I think it's
so fun. That's right,
and if you look closely, the costumes are different every time, but it
feels like each person is really wearing their own clothes. I can imagine the
picture of them receiving something.
[Music]
And it seems like the best thing comes out every time it comes out,
so
wouldn't it be Online Rise?
Then,I
Jiyeon
seems to have a bit of that kind of strong leadership charm.
Thank you.
[Music]
Makeup,
writer, writer, yeah, my sister, my
dream was to be a writer when I was young.
She started doing things like that on
YouTube and now she's
doing new combinations, and I
really like things that are delicious and recommended.  I think there will be a lot
[Music]